Americans are pressing for a very
different way of life if not completely
under lockdown it will certainly be
under a nationwide shutdown for the next
few months the CDC issuing these new
guidelines calling for an eight week ban
of large gatherings of 50 or more people
they say it's intended for anyone
organizing conferences festivals parades
concerts sporting events weddings and
just about anything else you can't
imagine there used to be part of our
regular daily lives
this comes as cities across the nation
close or restrict bars restaurants and
nightclubs the mayor of Los Angeles Eric
Garcetti closing not just bars and clubs
but also movie theaters bowling alleys
and gyms for the next month now earlier
this morning the Surgeon General dr.
Jerome Adams says we're in a crucial
window now in the situation here has the
potential to be Italy we are at a
critical inflection point in this
country people we are where Italy was
two weeks ago in terms of our numbers
and we have a choice to make as a nation
do we want to go the direction of South
Korea and really be aggressive in lower
or mortality rates or do we want to go
the direction of Italy and when you look
at the projections there's every chance
that we could be Italy but there's every
hope that we will be South Korea
meanwhile the president took to the
podium yesterday to play with the
American people that we are not running
out of food and to stop emptying the
shelves at the grocery stores this comes
as the president's task force also tells
us that we should expect a number of
cases to dramatically rise as testing
speeds up this week finally we may get
action because the Senate is back in
session and they'll pick up where the
House bill that just passed will have
been left over but Mitch McConnell's
saying there may be more bills needed to
address this crisis Griff Jenkins
kicking things off there in Washington
this morning thank you